[Music]
the hunt is on it's the first day of
qingyale wild boar season and these dogs
have caught the scent
it's a team effort in tuscany while they
scour the forest a fellow hunter waits
patiently in the hills above
he and others have staked out positions
across a wide territory waiting for the
right moment lone hunters like this one
are spread across the area waiting for
their team members to flush out the
chiangale with packs of dogs
nearby the sound of gunfire perhaps
another member of the team downhill
when we arrive we see they've had
success
hunting wild boar long central to tuscan
culture and cuisine has gained
the damage they've caused in recent
years is impressive they now come into
our gardens even our houses and into
town causing all kinds of damage you go
out to water your garden and you run
into a bore they even cause car crashes
hunters have cast their recreational
pursuit in a new light calling an out of
control population
just decades ago an estimated 50 000
bore roamed the whole country
that number has risen to 2 million
causing destruction and invading cities
viral videos like this one show a pack
of wild boars scouring rome for food
fertile ground with trash strewn on city
streets
here a family of boar corner a woman
with her groceries
across the country officials are testing
different strategies just after dawn
outside rome these park rangers check
traps that were set the night before
clearly a successful night
last year they caught more than 500
board at this reserve the head of the
program says an important goal is within
reach
uh
i believe if we can catch up to a
thousand or so a year we can bring back
a balance maintaining the biodiversity
while reducing damage to agriculture and
bringing down the number of wild boar
entering the city
of the five we saw in cages most were
juveniles
these people are quite young just a few
months old and park rangers say from a
population control point of view that's
a good thing because what they want to
do is catch the boar while they're still
young before they're able to reproduce
though not killed immediately the hard
truth is these boar will meet the same
fate as those we saw on the hunt they'll
soon be slaughtered for the local market
adam rainey al jazeera rome